[Music]
with dignity and respect committed to
free speech and common sense upbeat and
entertaining straight talking and direct
we may act eight each other and you
thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge now this week
forbes unveiled the best paid TV
presenters in the world Judy Scheindlin
better known as Judge Judy topped the
list earning nearly one hundred and
fifty million dollars a year
of course presenters should be paid
according to how good they are and what
they contribute to the program which is
why magic Karen and I paid handsomely a
forgets half of what we do and Nick is
forced to work tell me off after says we
need to get mating magic things to thin
blue line or treading on thin ice Karen
wants us to embrace our inner artist and
Nick is trying to escape but first it's
me Greg as it was supposed to be an
opportunity to build a bigger better
global britain instead i ineffectual PM
has delivered a deal that has not only
sold out gibraltar northern ireland our
fisherman and seventeen point four
million people she has also reduced this
mother of all democracies to a powerless
colony which would be forever enslaved
by the EU but worse in order to get her
farcical deal through parliament she's
now trying to manipulate the british
people with the kind of malevolent
propaganda not seen since world war ii
propaganda about a No Deal meaning we've
run out of food medicines and water the
economy will crash and will have the
worst recession in a century mrs. may
insists this is the best deal she could
get like Briggs it is some sorry damage
limitation exercise when had she had
some guts and determination it could
have been a bright new dawn for this
country and forget her much trumpeted
resilience that doesn't excuse this
catastrophic deal that has won
percent her fault this weekend her
letter to the British people mrs. Mae
said she put her heart and soul into
campaigning for the best deal pity she
hadn't put her heart and soul into
standing up to Barney Rinku if she had
this once great nation might not now be
a worldwide object of derision and pity
[Music]
you know I agree with so much of what
you've just said really this is a
hopeless deal this deal is dead as a
dodo
even before the vote it's what was
called in the House of Lords recently a
debate we had on the issue a hokey-cokey
brightened in out shake it all about and
it's a lose-lose for everybody nobody
wins out of this deal at all and and I
think that we've come to the stage now
two and a half years of negotiation what
I don't agree with what you've said is
that the EU is being made to be the
bogeyman the EU is the bad person they
bullied us they have not they've just
said you want to leave you've put down
your red lines that you're no more
single market no more customs union no
more European Court of Justice no more
movement of people you've boxed
yourselves in and then you have Northern
Ireland the Achilles heel it breaks it
which is a circle that cannot be squared
and now you're blaming us and all these
years for 45 years
you've opted into the European Union
what is today the European Union and
you've had lots of opt outs you're not
in Schengen you know it in the Euro now
you want to opt out and you want all the
opt-ins to be fair Karen I'm not
actually blaming at you I'm blaming her
I'm blaming her for not being a bit more
gutsy and negotiate whoever you blame
the position we're in now and what I've
hated about the position she's taken
throughout is it's my Deal or No Deal
it's only recently she has started to
say or no brexit so there is another
option and I don't think it's a Hobson's
choice of a bad deal which this is or no
deal there is another option which is we
remain at the European
in probably through people's vote no not
really big and there's another option as
a compromise which is staying in the
European IEA the Norway option is a
compromise the least worst option in
fact I was one of the named amendment
leaders where we won this vote in the
house I mean you might in that intro I
mentioned the propaganda that we're
seeing now which i think is shocking I
mean the stuff that Mark Carney has come
out with this week is shocking
you know this stuff shopping it's
worrying it's not boy because it's not
it's simply not true and he even he has
said that this is not a focus let's look
what the figures look at the figures
Connie has said a million jobs lost 30%
drop in house prices the worst recession
in 100 years nothing that man has said
before during or after the referendum
turned out return isn't that what he's
doing is trying to terrify people and
it's just not right can we just go to
some let's just have a look at what be
specifics of the tourism a still are and
then if I may I'll comment on that
cities may let's take a look she says
the deal consists of a transition period
that guarantees a transition period from
the 31st of March 2019 to December 2020
it will guarantee the rights of EU
citizens in the UK and UK citizens in
the EU tariff free trade tariffs free
trade I should say will continue there
are assurances that a soft border will
be maintained with the Republic of
Ireland but we will be paying a divorce
bill about of around 39 billion pounds
now this of course is but this is less
penal deal right I don't agree I agree
with Karen of course that I think this
is a bad opera both of you I think this
is a bad option for us but just on the
on the point of no deal if I may I think
Canada took 7 years to negotiate the
particular deal they have with the
European Union and that's without
passport een rights for the City of
London I just worry that without putting
it without talking of blame I think we
need to all of us probably need to move
beyond blame and say
talk about who's who's at fault for this
and actually start looking at the future
and how we can plan it best I just think
that actually a No Deal breaks it
without any form of agreement on pass
sporting rights on non-tariff barrier
barriers to trade on the existing legal
contracts that
we may have it will be inevitable in
that scenario that things will come to a
halt until we reinstitute those agree
did you read avidly Australian PM's he
did a piece this weeks outlining a
scenario in No Deal scenario which we
wouldn't impose tariffs on European
Goods Marconi I mean who's been
described by Jacob Riis morgue as a
failed kadian politician yeah that is
that is a sort of way people are being
attacked at the motor what about the
Treasury forecast the Treasury forecasts
correlate with the Bank of England's
forecast let's look at the figures let's
look at the Treasury forecast figures so
they say they've analyzed the cost of
breaks are looking at a 15 year period
they say the the UK's economic growth
would be two point five percent under
the government's checkers plan six point
seven percent less an average free trade
deal and it would be nine point three
percent less the Treasury gets it right
you really think they got it right I
just need to say that of course Mark
Carney's figures our worst case scenario
projections come back to me in a moment
f1 well it's just it's interesting to
hear people who support breakfast lining
up to attack the Treasury the Bank of
England the IFS if you know a secret
method to accurate economic forecasts
better than these institutions really
does do this which is what they've
already has said today it's not a fool
it's the instinct to attack the person
delivering the bad news rather than
analyzing the bad news that worries me
but anyway Carol you know I respect your
opinion we're not going to agree there's
no point rehashing all the arguments
except it's not a fork I haven't and
it's not have a question because what I
found really interesting in the last few
days is to see brexit ears saying what
we're facing is worse than remaining in
the EU
Rob has said it our own banks have said
it my question for you is if you think
that what the people really voted for
here is a No Deal scenario would you be
willing to put that back to people in a
second vote because now breaks the tears
are saying they too want a second
referendum because this was not the
terms of the original I love it nobody
deal nobody said no duis bhai said no
deal I love the deals but can I tell you
because it puts an end to it they have
the transition period they can do the
final but we have a country where we are
in many cities starting to lose the
streets to violent young thugs we can't
focus on that because brexit has sucked
the life out of this administration we
are approaching the winter where there
are very dire warnings about the
efficiency of our National Health
Service it has sucked the life out of it
we have schools where sadly they are
underperforming if this gets the brexit
if it means that we can of course it's
in reality in reality it's like most
things in life
I remember when in London Ken
Livingstone introduced a congestion
charge I will finish on this point and
we fought we fought almost like Karen
and Cour we used to fight on the radio
and one day the red light went off and
you have those marvelous off-mic moments
with the people you're interviewing and
Ken Livingstone leant forward to me and
he said some wise words he said do you
know what reality NIC congestion charge
will not be as great as I'm saying it's
gonna be and it's not gonna be as dire
as you're saying is going to be with
most things in life it will be in the
middle and that's what I think about
Britain it's not there is a point you've
said that's the end of it it's not
you've got the chance got 585 pages of
just the withdrawal agreement which is
three issues Northern Ireland people's
rights in the 39 billion pounds the main
issue is what is the future going to be
like for us and that is 26 pages of
waffle right it's it's not legal
it's got to be negotiated over the next
few years they say the end of 2020 we've
already said we might to extend it
beyond 2020 to 2022 then on top of that
the backstop with northern I will keep
us if we cannot remove ourselves so if
the uncertainty continues
we cannot be in a position wait a second
we cannot be in a position we cannot
accept the backs of things we can't be
in a position where the EU gets to say
if when and how we leave currently we
have the freedom to leave if we want to
right we can't let them to question can
i just if we do that quickly bring in
what jean-claude juncker the president
of European Commission said because just
pick up a mix point just to clarify that
a better deal is not actually an option
right now this is what
Janka says I'm inviting those who have
to ratify this deal in the House of
Commons to take this in consideration
this is the best deal possible for
Britain this is the best impossible for
Europe this is the only possible yes I
hear you but it's a fantasy this deal
have got no hope in hell Jeremy Corbyn
finally seems so found his sense of
humor haven't the Prime Minister said
this is the best possible deal it's the
only possible deal well I mean to say
it's not hard to be the best deal if
it's the only deal by definition by
therefore mr. speaker by definition it's
also the worst deal never thought I'd
say